من بيروت ينضم وليد العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه عميد الياس
اهلا وسهلا بك الان تم الحديث عن سد كفكه
عن جسر انطونوف على نهر دنبرو عن الانسحاب
الروسي وتشكيك اوكراني في هذا الانسحاب
الى الضفه اليسرى من النهر برايك ما الذي
يجري تحضير له في خيرسون من الجانب الروسي
ويخشاه الجانب الاوكراني ويتعامل معه بهذا
الحذر
زين العابدين الخشيه الاكرانيه ان يكون
هناك خدعه معينه لاستدراج القوات
الاوكرانيه الى حرب شوارع في مدينه خرسان
وبالتالي استنزاف القوات الاوكرانيه عددا
وعده ومنعها من التعامل مع ما يحدث مثلا
او ما يحدث في اقليم حركات في صفوف ولكن
اليوم يبدو المعادله التاليه انه اصبح
الامر بشكل كبير جدا كي تكون خدعه ولكنه
صعب جدا للقبول العسكريه وسياسيا على رئيس
بوتين كي لا يكون هناك مقابل على سبيل
النساء تفجير الجسور هذا امر يناقض
المنطقه العسكري لان الانسحاب يتطلب همم
طرقا امنه للعبور فاذا لا تدمر الجسور قبل
عبورها ولكن يبقوا يبقى من 20 الى 30,000
جندي في الضفه الغربيه لانها كيف ستعبر هي
والي والمده المطلوبه وهذا الامر لا اعتقد
انه خلال يوم او يومين وحتى اسابيع كيف
ستعبر وكيف ستعود يعني تفجير روسيا لهذين
الجزرين همم هل يعني ان الانسحاب هذا
النهائي وروسيا لا تفكر بالعوده الى منطقه
ضمتها مؤخرا اليها
هذا هو الامر هذا مؤشر اساسي المرحله سهام
المرحله القادمه كيف ستكون ما هي
الاولويات للجيش الروسي الحديث عن تفجير
سد نوفكار 15 مليون متر مكعب نتحدث عن 15
مليون طن من المياه هذا امر يضر بالجيش
الروسي كما يضر بالجيش همم الاوكراني يبدو
ان هناك تحديد الاولويات معينه للمرحله
القادمه
التثبيت في ذا فروج على سبيل المثال
وحمايه العقد الاساسيه مدينه مليتو بول
وبالتالي منع جيش الاوكراني من الذهاب
واحتلال واسترداد سباته وكريمينا وحتى
ايضا المحاولات السيطره واا دخول مدينه
بخمود هذه هي الامور الاساسيه ولكن هذا
الامر يتطلب جهد اعداد عسكري اعداد لوجستي
وهذا الامر سيؤخذ وقت بعد مرحله الشتاء
اذا صح التعبير بالنظر الى تطورات هذه
المعركه معركه خيرسون وتقدم القوات
الاوكرانيه منذ اسابيع والقذف المستمر
هل يمكن استبعاد ان الجيش الروسي اضطر
فعلا لترك المدينه
بالطبع يعني القرار قرار رسمي زين
العابدين يعني عندما تحدث الجنرال المعين
حديثا مع وزير الدفاع والملفت للنظر هو
غياب الرئيس بوتين عن هذا الامر وهذا امر
مهم جدا نتحدث عن حركاب نتحدث عن همم سبب
الانسحاب ذكر ما يسمى بالحفاظ على الارواح
هذا امر له مفعول في الداخل الروسي
للاحتياط الذي استدعيه وقلق الاهالي على
على اولادهم هذا الامر يدل ان هناك معدله
ومشكله عملانيه تكيه في كيفيه التعامل مع
الحرب في اوكرانيا تبدا من 24 شباط الى
اركاب واليوم نتحدث عن خير
العسكريه من بيروت شكرا جزيلا لك